you know what's worse than a market
crash a reverse market crash a concept
I've been talking about on the podcast
so what is a reverse market crash that's
when all of a sudden the market just
balloons up and you're like wait a
minute what happened and you're trying
to hold it and you see the rich get rich
and the poor get poor now you may say
Pat how's that even possible I want you
to look at this chart from Pure research
everybody that's a politician that
becomes a governor or Congress or Senate
they all want to claim we got to help
the middle class we got to help middle
income but look what this data is
telling us from Pew research according
to this data if you look look at the
green at the top that's upper income
aggregate wealth in the US yellow is
Middle America middle income and the
light green is lower income to the left
the wealth in America only 60% of it was
with upper income back in 1983 32 was
with middle and seven was with lower
fast forward to 2016 it's even worse
today it went from 60% of the wealth to
79% middle income went from 32% of the
wealth down to7 that's a drop of nearly
50% and lower income went from 7% to 4
that's a drop off of 40% so you may be
asking where are we going with this this
is the point every time we're printing
money to assume and say these
politicians we're helping the loan
middle-income family you give them money
guess what they don't know how to do
they don't know how to save they're
experts at spending the government
doesn't teach them how to save they just
give them the money and they know
they're going to spend and then when
they spend it what do they buy they buy
a product somebody owes them they owe
this they buy a camera they buy a drink
it goes to the companies so you give the
money to the poor knowing the money is
really not being given to the poor it's
going to flow to the top which is who
the rich that's how the rich keep
getting richer and the poor keep getting
poorer and these policy not going to
stop by the way the other day Dr Powell
says he's not raising the rates you know
what happened to the S&P 500 boom 5%
within a week so what if all of a sudden
Po in the next few months they we
lowering the rates we're lowering the
rates you could see s SMP and DOW just
go boom boom boom boom boom which is
called a reverse market crash something
the wealthy would want not something you
would want for low and Middle America
we're going to talk about that today
okay so if you get value out of this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel let's get right into it
I'm going to give you a few examples of
what a reverse market crash could look
like case studies actual reality what
happened one is Germany one is Zimbabwe
one is Iran one is Argentina one is
turkey and maybe a couple other ones but
let's start off with Germany so back in
the days in 1914 1913 or so if you
wanted to buy a dollar and convert your
currency from Germany marks to a dollar
you needed four marks again this is 1914
so hey here's four marks here's $1 you
with me so far nine years later in 1923
you know how much it took to just get
one Us doll how many marks one trillion
marks did you hear what I just said it
took 1 trillion marks to get $1 and it
only happened in 9 years now why let me
explain after losing World War I the
Treaty of Versa forced Germany $33
billion in reparations so during this
time Germany lost a significant amount
of territory where it was Manufacturing
Goods they were forced to print money to
meet the reparation demands this
simultaneously added money too and
removed goods from the economy
catastrophic by 1922 price had risen by
nearly 700% causing hyperinflation the
government had to print million Mark
notes then billion Mark notes and by the
way you ever hear the saying a
wheelbarrow full of money couldn't even
buy a newspaper this is kind of where it
comes from because this is when it went
from four marks buying a dollar to a
trillion marks buying $1 us and by the
way just to kind of show you some data
here if you look at this chart here this
shows you from 1918 where it you know
took roughly 100 marks to buy US dollar
look how quickly it goes 5 years later
to a trillion marks right that chart
tells an entire story you ever wonder
why Jamie Diamond CEO of Chase has a
$900 million art collection or Steve
Cohen $1.1 billion art collection or
Microsoft has nearly a billion doll
collection the company 5,000 art pieces
in 180 different locations worldwide why
because billionaires and millionaires
understand one of the ways to hedge
against inflation money being printed
market crash interest rates is to buy
non duplicatable assets and one of them
is Art Fine Arts and that's why today's
sponsor is Masterworks let me tell you a
little bit about Masterworks you may be
watching the same P I'm not a
millionaire or a billionaire I can't
afford to buy warhall or Banky or basat
how am I going to buy that well
Masterworks allows you to buy fractional
shares like buying a share of Apple you
buy a share of a bank seit painting or a
Warhol piece you're able to do that
through Masterworks this is why over
800,000 people have signed up with
Masterworks offerings have sold out
within minutes and many of you have
already created accounts and some of you
that haven't this is your chance to skip
the waiting list and start your
collection today just click on the link
in the description go to
masterworks.io government attempted a
land redistribution effort which
disrupted the farming industry causing
an agricultural production collapse
after monthly inflation Peak by one
measure at 79.6 billion per the
government in 2009 abolished their
dollar and began using US dollar instead
the currency switch brought monetary
stability for a few years until the
Reserve Bank of Zimbabwe could no longer
meet the demand for US dollar money
stored in a bank accounts could no
longer be withdrawn in cash and in early
2019 the Central Bank reintroduced the
Zimbabwe changing US dollar denominated
savings and domestic government debts
into a local currency of rapidly
declining value you want to know what
this did to the stock market take a look
at this this is Zimbabwe's stock market
notice how everything is flat smooth
everything's good maybe a slight pick up
there and all of a sudden boom stock
market skyrockets to
57,4 12 now that that's the stock market
but what caused this take a look at the
inflation rate if we look at this chart
here upwards of 800% and if you go to
their interest rates look what their
interest rates went up too 200% can you
imagine buying Al on 200% interest rate
that's what happened to the Zimbabwe now
some people will say that'll never
happen to the US just never going to
happen because those were not real
interest rates and now you may be saying
Pat I mean I know how you're doing this
with the inflation rate and interest
rate but that's not the real interest
rate well if you want to look at the
real interest here's what you'd be
looking at even if you look at this look
what the real interest rate was in 2022
minus 30% what do you do with minus 30%
do they pay you like if 10% I'm paying
are you paying me now when it's- 30%
imagine how much of a show was in
Zimbabwe and by the way if you want to
calculate that in us the real interest
rate would be if inflation is 5% and
interest rates are three the real
interest rate is a difference between
the five and a three making a two here
it's 30% minus 30% in Zimbabwe so that's
Zimbabwe now let's take a look at
Argentina here's Argentina for you 70
years of welfare policies a third of the
workforce is employed by the state most
spending goes towards salaries and
pensions instead of Investments
technology and infrastructure fiscal
deficit for the last 13 years constant
Printing and borrowing biggest IMF
borrow a third of IMF debt as of 2023
there were price caps on over 1,300
consumer products and what does this do
when you take free market out take a
look at their stock market what it did
from 2020 look at that chart right there
it went from roughly 20,000 to what
nearly 640,000 that's what you call a
explosive reverse market crash and what
would their rates similar situation
you're looking at here as Zimbabwe not
as bad so I'm going to show you this
again if look at this chart with
Argentina's real interest rates notice
this they're also in the negatives right
and if you look at the bottom the
difference between interest rates and
inflation you typically want interest
rates to be ahead of inflation notice
what happens in 2022 when inflation they
bring the interest rates down hoping to
fix the economy what happens to
inflation gets ahead of it and now
they're chasing after inflation to not
lose it the reason why we're showing you
this because in America if Powell all of
a sudden gets pressure from the top to
say lower interest rates inflation could
go back up again quickly so managing
this and how they could lose control
over it it's going to be a lot of
pressure on Powell to not be tempted to
want to please an Administration and
hold it together now we'll see what
we're going to do if he lets loose you
talking about reverse market crash will
experience in the US now let's take a
look at Turkey okay they got the number
one military in the Middle East if you
look at turkey last October inflation
hit a 24-year high with 85.5% on an
annualized basis meaning prices nearly
doubled erigon started cutting rates
while the US was hiking in 2022 against
the advice of several turkey Central
Bankers that he ended up firing and what
happens to the turkey stock market what
do you think take a look at this same
thing it goes from 1,000 roughly to
7700 that's
700% increase in just a couple years and
what were their real interest rates what
do you think take a look at this also in
the negatives and if you look at their
inflation guess what you're looking on
this next chart same exact issue notice
a trend it's a similar thing happening
America and Jerome Powell's got to keep
it together or else we're going to have
similar things happening here let's
continue Iran here's Iran for you look
at their stock market same exact thing
2018 2019 2020 slightly of a growth and
in 2020 to 2021 boom Skyrocket to 2
million and then eventually to 2.5
million their stock market and if you
look at Iran's inflation rate what do
you notice take a look at this it's not
as high as some of these other guys but
40% 60% interest rates upwards of 22%
and then here real interest rates in
Iran guess where it's at it fell down to
negative as well and they trying to
control it ever since similar issues and
last case study here is Venezuela
Venezuela's High inflation levels are
due to relying heavily on Imports for
basic go depending on oil as its main
export inefficient government Industries
governmental corruption price controls
government subsidies and most of all
sanctions May 18 2006 president Hugo
Chavez from Venezuela declared on
Tuesday that Venezuela would consider
putting the sale of its oil in Euros in
2017 Trump aggressively tightening
sanctions with the aim of outing Madura
in favor an interim opposition
government government led by ju Guido
the Trump Administration cut off by
maduro's regime's access to the US
Financial system barred us companies and
citizens from purchasing Venezuela debt
and block pdvsa from exporting to the
United States its primary destination by
the end of his term Trump had issued
seven executive orders targeting state
or Affiliated companies government
agencies and the Central Bank
Venezuela's hyperinflation rate
increased from 9,000 plus% to 10 million
per from 2018 to 2019 according to the
IMF and by the way if you take a look at
this chart from Venezuela's inflation
rate from 85 to 2024 look what happens
after Trump did that to Venezuela in
2017 it's
skyrockets all the way up to what
65,7 4% inflation look what happens
their stock market the most bipolar
stock market you can think about where
it goes from a couple thousand to 62,000
causing a reverse market crash so take a
look at this next chart of OPEC crude
oil what happened in Venezuela their
export kept going lower and lower and
lower because that's what sanctions do
and again with their interest rates
skyrocketing all the way up to 50 40 60%
and they also had negative interest
rates all the way down to 20% now to to
give some hope to Venezuela take a look
at this year 2014 15 16 17 everything is
declined just barely they came back up
in 21 and 22 because President Biden is
willing to release the sanctions so they
can start selling oil again if Maduro is
willing to have free and fair elections
that means we have to trust he's going
to do it whether he will or not we won't
know but he said he will now you may be
saying Pat this is great all these
examples you're giving we're not
Zimbabwe we're not turkey we're not Iran
we're not Venice are you out of your
mind that'll never happen to us in the
US okay let me show you a couple things
here take a look maybe you're right
maybe I'm wrong who knows but if you
look at our inflation rate from 2000
till today notice what happened in 2021
22 skyrockets right look at the rates on
the next page our real interest rates if
you look at that we went into negative
slightly okay now 2020 goes into
negative 2013 we flirt with negative and
if you look at our effective rate uh at
the southern chart you'll also notice
where we went there we were also
flirting with 0 0 for God knows how long
and take a look at S&P 500 look at this
here SPX what do you notice and roughly
in 2009 SPX was at 700 where is it at
now roughly 4,300 it's 6X that quickly
you mean to tell me that can go 6X like
this that's what the chart is telling me
in America for it to happen what are the
criterias what do we notice here number
one in every one of these countries we
have quanitative easing which is what
printing money we did a lot of that in
US number two is when the government
chooses to get involved with free market
and they want to kind of create
regulation and all these rules we got a
little bit of that going on what's
number three price controls you got to
put the price of oil at these some
people want to flirt with it new some
wanted to Flo with it Biden wanted to
Flo with it those are the areas when you
hear languages like that we have
problems coming up here now why will it
not happen in the states that's a fair
question so again the three is what
quantitative ising which is printing you
got getting involved in fre free market
and price controls but outside of that
who's typically screwing this single
like who's going to ruin this great idea
called America politicians by what more
welfare spending more money printing
couple things that may come up is if
this idea of reparations becomes
something that they want to do and then
you and I got to pay for it and we've
never been a part of it I'm from Iran my
family to be involved with this but we
got to pay for it because this is what
America wants to do or Ubi there's just
a lot of things going on by the way the
other threat is the following US dollar
we know it's strong you know we already
talked about the 80% and the 60%
currency world use them but what if all
of a sudden these guys that are having
these meetings right the the world
economic Forum or all these other
meetings that we're having these Summits
that they're getting together let's
create a cbdc that the whole world uses
everybody around the world uses the same
exact you know Central Bank digital
currency that we use no longer the US
dollar you know what happens to us we
lose a leverage that's not a good thing
we want to keep and maintain that
leverage as we have the money that
allows us to keep us safe because people
rely on the dollar trust me a big part
of our economy is staying strong is the
reason why America is a pretty safe
place to be at as well we give that up
we give up leverage then you're helping
the enemy and other countries that we do
not want to do that but if we stay put
we Monitor and hold our politicians
accountable and presidents that want to
keep printing money and we scream off
the top of our lungs like slow it down
we want accountability we want to see
what kind of money you're spending on we
want to be kind of pump your bricks on
all this money we spend if we do that we
have a shot at this reverse market crash
not taking place in America specifically
if Powell doesn't all of a sudden start
being tempted to lower the rates if you
got value add of this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
if you've not seen what they did to
measure inflation in a whole different
way than they did before click here to
watch that video take care everybody
bye-bye